i actually am grateful for the bullying
and all that stuff because that actually
spurned me on to be really good to prove
them wrong to get out of devon where i
was from a very small town and prove
that i could do something in my life
don't be afraid to be different
what does that mean
um
don't be afraid to be different i think
we often feel we have to conform to what
society wants us to be or
family wants us to be or
but being yourself you know everyone
else has taken so being yourself is it
sounds so easy but it's actually not
because i think we
we have all these different masks based
on trauma or based on things that we've
been told aren't great but i think the
more we can take them off the more we
can celebrate our our true self
and i think a lot of healing comes from
sharing that um you know you're as dirty
as your secrets so i think if you can um
if you can be brave to be bold and
daring
um you'll be rewarded for it and it will
feel better i think we sometimes create
a box that we have to put ourselves in
um and that's ourselves putting
ourselves in so i think if we can
um
yeah
dare to be different i think it's a
it's important any and in any profession
you talked about being bullied
when you were younger and i think that's
maybe a common thing that people who are
creative go through because
they do have a
different way that they look at the
world and maybe it's threatening to
other people i don't know what the
reasons are but
how long did it take you to feel okay
that
i don't have to fit in i can if i want i
choose to be me
um
god i've only recently in the last
probably a couple of years
realized that i'm actually okay being me
um i think i started getting bullied
when i was about eight years old
and i didn't even know really why it was
happening it wasn't
um i just thought i was different there
was something wrong with me um it was
probably because i was more effeminate
and maybe
a little
you know i don't know maybe i was a bit
over the top i don't know exactly why
but i was just different and a lot of
the kids couldn't quite understand me
and then it got kind of worse as i got
into my teenage years
there was violence
punched for no reason just kind of and i
then had to kind of hide
and that's when i started to
create a masculine kind of tough persona
to kind of protect myself
and then i started to believe that
persona
um
to the point of
i became you know this kind of arrogant
guy that wasn't really me but it was
just a you know i kept my guard up so
i wouldn't the the violence and the kind
of abuse wouldn't continue
and then um
yeah
people just started to see it as being
disingenuous and i think certain people
around me started seeing seeing the real
me and were like you know what is this
thing you're
presenting it's
it's not you there's something much more
beautiful inside of you and gradually
the crack started to happen
and
yeah but it was only i'm now 36 so i'd
say it's taking me a long time to get
comfortable with who i am it's taken a
really long time
and i did this interesting thing called
bufo last year which is
5 meow dmz a little bit like ayahuasca
and it's great for anxiety depression
trauma ptsd and
it really set me free of uh the pain and
the trauma i encountered and it made me
understand
all the years of the abuse i've been
giving myself
and i finally let go of it it was just
an incredible
incredible relief to actually know i'm
okay
um there's nothing wrong with me
because for so many years i actually
thought there was something really wrong
with me and i was a bad guy i was a bad
kid i was the gay side of me was just
awful
you know i was less than i was inferior
and
just living with that on a day-to-day
basis
i didn't really think it was affecting
me but it must have been affecting me in
a really significant way
my behavior was acting out
numbing myself with alcohol drugs
toxic relationships
and
it feels really great to not be in that
place in my life anymore i'm just really
relieved and it's taken a long time
but anyone that's struggling
with anything like that just know it's
not your fault it's it's really
it's really not your fault and you can
get better and you can get over it it
just takes time to be patient with
yourself you have to be kind to yourself
trust yourself and know that you're an
amazing human being
but you also had success because you
were a dancer at and you you were a
dancer for madonna at one time so you
you had
a life that was working it sounds like
you were able to
um perform and you were in demand
yeah that said all that stuff i was
doing i did have a really great ride as
being a dancer and i think thank god i
was
thank god i really committed to the
discipline of becoming a good dancer i
was very ambitious i loved it and if i
hadn't have been a good dancer and if i
hadn't have had that success i don't
know what i've been doing
the dancing really got me out of a dark
place and it gave me so many
opportunities so many adventures i met
so many wonderful people and it's a
really euphoric feeling being a dancer
it's the best feeling in the world i
mean it really is once you're on stage
there's nothing better than that
so i'm really grateful
that despite you know even and i think i
actually am grateful for the bullying
and all that stuff because that actually
spurned me on to be really good to prove
them wrong to get out of devon where i
was from a very small town and prove
that i could do something in my life
so despite you know the way i look at it
is
those situations
were part of my fuel
and um i was just so determined to
succeed at something
that um
yeah
i made it i made it a priority that i
would
reach a certain level
and the shiru process parallels some of
this
you know and you talked about the the
was i'm not sure the substance that you
were able to use to kind of but was she
using ayahuasca there was something that
in in the film that she has these
epiphanies or you know she's able to
transcend
so yeah in the sure process they they do
masculine
um and it's a similar thing um then it's
i have never tried it but i've heard
it's very good
for letting go um yeah and uh
a lot of these retreats in different
places they use psychedelics to help
with trauma ptsd repression
so it's it's quite common use right and
sorry i didn't mean to give spoilers
away so if you know we can take it out
but um i know it sounds like there was a
similar journey in the shrew process and
um
you know i i think
that there's some it sounds like there's
parallels maybe to why you wrote it or
no the sure process is a very personal
story to me as um growing up my parents
encountered some charlatan gurus and
some quack doctors
my mother was falsely diagnosed with
ovarian cancer and given some quite
unorthodox
techniques to heal her and then we found
out she didn't have ovarian cancer
the doctor actually was not your doctor
he ended up going to jail for sexual
abuse and he's still in jail and growing
up they encountered other people um that
were i come from a very new age town and
so i didn't feel safe a lot of the time
there were people coming in my parents
are very trusting very loving people and
um they were taken advantage of a lot of
times
they actually wound up in a cult they
didn't even know about
and
i think it was a very uncertain and
unstable
kind of lifestyle
and i just
growing up with that i wanted to kind of
highlight the dangers but also show the
positive
effects of self-development it's not
that i'm on self-development
it's more be careful of false prophets
and who you put your trust in because a
lot of them don't have the psychology
psychological training to take people to
that vulnerable place
um and if you see the movie you can see
the dangers but you can also see the
positive effects too so we were
interested in highlighting the duality
of those characters that want to take
advantage of you but also want to help
you
right yeah i grew up in the bay area and
there were
groups we won't name them but where you
wouldn't be able to leave to go to the
bathroom for several hours and it was
you know
all to sort of strengthen you and
different things like that so yeah
that sounds uncomfortable
yeah i'd hate to see the line for the
bathroom after it yeah you were told you
could go but yeah so i realized there's
a because you want to believe
there's a you can be seduced by
individuals like that you know they they
kind of tell you what you want to hear
they're very intuitive
um but yeah you can
definitely fall prey
as we're seeing with different
documentaries and things yeah we're now
being commoditized on social media so
they can actually
find out how to target you
so it's a whole new wave and especially
coming out of covid
with people you know looking for help
there's a lot of
unfortunately dangerous predators in
that field
um that don't really
have the skills they present
and i feel and i don't want to give away
too much here so maybe i'll i'll tone it
down but your character has an arc once
she starts to
sense that something's wrong and that
it's not necessarily her
so it seems like the the fingers are
being pointed at her but then she starts
to have more of an arc once she
discovers
uh there's
trouble in paradise what well yeah i
want to what i wanted to show about um
shuru
is because i think a lot of movies
portray
these gurus is either like the arch
villain
or
you know a huge sexual predator and a
lot of the time they get can be but i
wanted to show a very realistic
charismatic guru type
the hipster kind of guru which now is a
lot of them and just show that there's
it's not black and white because it
never is completely black and white
because everyone in the retreat does
have a really positive experience but
that isn't necessarily about him that's
because they took the first step to
wanting to grow to wanting to let go so
it's kind of showing that
if you want to grow if you want to
change you can do it it's within you you
don't necessarily need to go on a get
rich weekend or a retreat to start the
work